y nos dicen un estudiante construye un
circuito con una batería y dos resistor
es en serie la resistencia r 2 es el
doble que la resistencia r 1 abajo se
muestra la gráfica de la energía perdida
por r 1 a lo largo del tiempo esta
gráfica que tenemos a la izquierda cuál
de las siguientes muestra la energía
perdida en r 2 a lo largo del tiempo en
términos de e
y tenemos estas cuatro opciones pausa el
vídeo e intenta descubrirlo por tu
cuenta
ok vamos a trabajar juntos
primero visualicemos el circuito esta es
nuestra batería por lo tanto esta es la
terminal positiva y esta la negativa y
después tenemos en nuestro primer
resistor y después a nuestro segundo
resistor y nos dicen que estos resistor
es están en serie
este será r 1 y este ere 2 ahora si
tenemos un circuito como éste donde
ninguna parte está en paralelo la
corriente que fluye a lo largo del
circuito será constante por lo tanto
podemos decir que para cualquier punto
en el circuito la corriente que
llamaremos i es constante también nos
dicen cómo están relacionadas estas
resistencias si suponemos que el 1 tiene
una resistencia de no sé
homs nos dicen que la resistencia en r2
es el doble que la resistencia en r1 por
lo tanto si uno tiene una resistencia de
x ohms r2 tendrá una resistencia de 2x
oms ahora pensemos si esta es la gráfica
de la energía que se disipa a través de
r1 a lo largo del tiempo cuál será la
energía que se disipará a través de r2 a
lo largo del tiempo para eso pensemos en
términos de potencia y energía y lo que
conocemos de ellas sabemos que la
potencia es la energía disipada sobre el
tiempo por ejemplo podemos escribir que
la potencia es igual a la energía
disipada sobre el tiempo y podemos verlo
como el cambio en el voltaje a través
del resistor por la corriente a través
de él si queremos una expresión la
energía total disipada en el tiempo
podemos fijarnos en esta parte de aquí
podríamos multiplicar a ambos lados por
delta t por lo tanto podemos escribir
que la energía disipada es igual al
cambio de voltaje a través del resistor
por la corriente que pasan a través del
resistor por el cambio en el tiempo
ahora bien si empezamos ente igual a
cero nuestro cambio en el tiempo será el
tiempo en el que nos fijemos menos cero
entonces tendremos cualquier tiempo en
el que estemos por lo tanto escribiré t
en lugar de delta de t ahora el cambio
de voltaje a través del resistor ya lo
hemos visto antes será el valor de la
corriente que fluye por ese resistor por
la resistencia por lo tanto si tomamos
esta información y sustituimos por delta
b en nuestra primera expresión que
obtenemos obtendremos que la energía
disipada será igual a la corriente que
fluye a través del resistor por la
resistencia por la corriente que fluye a
través del registro por el tiempo o
podemos escribir que la energía disipada
como una función de estas tres variables
será la corriente al cuadrado por la
resistencia por el tiempo
ahora bien gracias a la gráfica dada
sabemos que en tf1 tenemos una energía
disipada de
eso con una resistencia de x oms por lo
tanto podemos decir que la energía
disipada 1 es igual a cuadrada por x
esa es la resistencia por t 1
ahora pensemos en cuál será la energía
disipada en t1 pero en nuestro segundo
resistor si regresamos a nuestra
expresión original la energía disipada
será igual a tf1 por la corriente que
como sabemos es la misma corriente que
fluye por ambos resistor es ya que
recuerda están en serie por lo tanto
tenemos la misma corriente y cuadrada y
ahora cuál es la resistencia bueno en
lugar de x tenemos 2x así que podemos
escribir esto como 2 por y cuadrada por
x por t 1
ahora observa esto que tenemos aquí era
justo en la misma cantidad de energía
que se disipaban en el tiempo de uno en
nuestro primer resistor esto es a 1
por lo tanto entre 1 la energía disipada
en nuestro segundo resistor será el
doble entonces lo que queremos observar
es que para tf1 tengamos el doble de
energía disipada esta gráfica de abajo
solo tiene un cuarto de la energía
disipada en definitiva no es lo que
buscamos y podemos cancelar la está de
arriba es la mitad de la energía que
buscamos por lo tanto también voy a
cancelar la esta gráfica a la derecha
tiene la misma cantidad de energía por
lo tanto no es lo que buscamos y puedo
cancelarla y aquí en t1 tenemos el doble
de energía disipada por lo tanto esta es
la opción que buscábamos
otra forma de pensarlo es que si tenemos
la misma corriente que fluye a través de
los dos resistor es el segundo resistor
tiene el doble de resistencia que el
primero entonces en cualquier tiempo
dado para el segundo resistor disiparán
el doble de energía que el primero dicho
de otra manera tendremos el doble de
pendiente en esa recta
es por ello que de manera clara esta
gráfica que seleccionamos tiene el doble
de la pendiente que la primera o podemos
decir que para cualquier tiempo es decir
dt igual a cero atte igual a 1 disipamos
el doble de energía por lo tanto en
lugar de 1 disip haremos dos veces
uno y hemos acabado nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo